greetings you [ __ ] it's monday
march 15th
i miss you little dirty bastards anyway
from the heart of jersey the joint is
brought to you by
draftkings i don't know if you're living
in a [ __ ] coma
or you're hanging out with ichabod crane
the guy that went to sleep and woke up
40 years later with a beard
i think that's his name it don't matter
the biggest college ball basketball
tournament
of the year is eating up the brackets
came out yesterday listen
get your [ __ ] hemorrhoid ass off that
bench
and get into the tournament action for
four bucks on an underdog if they win
you're up 264 dollars did you [ __ ]
hear me
that's 64-1 odds that's [ __ ] crazy
who's gonna win i don't [ __ ] know you
think you do
all it takes is four bucks to get a
winning 256 dollar [ __ ] winner
that's a [ __ ] real stimulus check
where's joe biden
i guarantee he's betting four dollars to
get a shot at winning 265
56 [ __ ] dollars there's no better way
to put your college basketball knowledge
to the test
than to put your money where your mouth
is with draftkings sportsbook app
listen i love them it's a [ __ ]
adventure
it's fun it's easy they pay
when you want to it's your [ __ ] money
so do me a favor
download the top draftking sportsbook
app
today right now it's [ __ ] monday it's
the beginning
of march insanity over there at
draftkings
use promo code joy when you sign up to
turn four dollars
into 256 dollars listen if you're paying
me five dollars at patreon quit right
now
this is a better deal for you you might
as well quit
[ __ ] take a dollar buy some bubble
gum and [ __ ]
win 256 dollars
for a limited time only at draftking
sportsbook app
and here's the part the lawyers make me
say you got to be 21 or older get your
hat with the propeller
and shout up your ass new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only
new customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now do you have a
gaming problem i'm sympathetic to you
call 1-800 to gambler and indiana 1-809
with it my mother was a degenerate and
they [ __ ] killed it
so if you got problems take care of it
but if you don't [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] march insanity over at
draftkings
and for four bucks you can make 256
bucks
are you [ __ ] is that something wrong
with you go bang your head off the
[ __ ]
wall 15 times and download the draftking
sportsbook app
and press code joey you understand me
draftkings sportsbook app now
and tell him i sent you the joint is
also brought to you by cbd
lion the [ __ ] masters they have put
me through this [ __ ] surgery
i am off the [ __ ] pain pills i'm tip
top magoo
i'm ready to stab three [ __ ]
anybodies i don't care who the [ __ ] they
are
cbd whether it's the kinesiology tape
the chocolate the extra strength cbd
unscented lion oil and capsules
and the bat the body listen however you
want cbd
it's given to you by cbd line vapor pens
gummy bears i mean listen they have
helped me dramatically i'm on the
tincture now
that thing is works wonders and for pain
let me tell you something
i'm off the [ __ ] pain pills that's
all that matters cbd
lion is battle tested through uncle joey
for [ __ ] surgery so put that in your
pup
[ __ ] pipe and smoke it the joint is
also brought to you by one of my [ __ ]
favorites of all time
manscaped you got to take care of your
balls
you got to take care of your balls it's
tournament season
it's going to be balls to the walls
everywhere you look
avoid the upset and trim that [ __ ]
nut sack with manscape
that trimmer is the real champ listen to
this
you hear that that's the lawnmower 3.0
the best trimmer known to mankind i
would shave an eyebrow off to show you
how effective it is
but i need it to [ __ ] brow beat
[ __ ] the only ball trimmer
with advanced skin technology that won't
snick
or snag your nut sack protect your
little basketballs of life
when you get in batman when you get
manscaped you also have
helping give back to testosterone cancer
society
and they're supporting their families
and their survivors
manscape wants to save all the balls
particularly balls of guys between the
ages of 35
and between 15 and 35 who are most at
risk so work with me here guys this
ain't a [ __ ] joke
take care of yourself take care of
yourself inside and take care of
yourself
outside shave that [ __ ] eddie monster
looking dick of yours
get some [ __ ] manscape to the [ __ ]
nut sack
no [ __ ] uh anxiety fondle your balls
[ __ ] it's for science
and buy some manscape they got
everything they got the crop preserver
the
crop reviver the crop ball wipes their
little ones you put them in your [ __ ]
wallet
you bump into some [ __ ] that needs
a fix
you turn around you take the little ball
wipe out you wash your balls real quick
you don't want somebody sucking a bad
taste in your dick you got a bad yelp
review
anyway clean out that stinky nose hair
with the weed whacking
and now your balls could smell as good
as you with their cologne
name refined i [ __ ] love it it's
tremendous
i spray it on my neck and spray it on my
ball sack
so they match you understand me so the
balls are connected with the soul
it's a beautiful thing nobody treats
your balls
as good as manscaped so do me a favor
right now
get 20 percent off and free shipping at
manscape.com
joey again that's manshape.com
joey it's march check your [ __ ] balls
[ __ ] do me a favor
now without further ado
let's get this [ __ ] party
started welcome to the joint
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's monday the 15th
of [ __ ] march we're halfway through
the goddamn month already can you
[ __ ] believe that [ __ ]
and i gotta tell you something i'm
wearing my little blue shirt
and my [ __ ] little light blue to
bring happiness into your life but i
can't
i i got i gotta be honest with you
people today
i'm a little low on a monday uh i'm here
for you guys always you know i'm a
[ __ ]
animal i'm always ready or rocked but
i'm a little low
today uh i'm very upset over the
jennifer lopez
j.lo broke up with uh the bag
alex rodriguez and i i i just can't
[ __ ] believe they broke up i was
cheering for them
are you people [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] that they broke up
she just ate up another poor [ __ ]
soul you know what i'm saying she's
eating a puff diddy
[ __ ] puff daddy's cousin uh [ __ ]
ben affleck how to get a new wig
[ __ ] alex rodriguez this [ __ ] is a
[ __ ] listen
i've been telling you for years i love
puerto rican people i love them to that
they're the closest thing to cubans when
they were
i avoid puerto rican women like [ __ ]
that that they'll wear you the [ __ ] down
poor [ __ ] alex rodriguez for months
had to be [ __ ] going
make him believe he liked the new song
nobody likes that [ __ ] [ __ ] can you
imagine
them playing that [ __ ] in your house how
do you like and then [ __ ] they start
dancing to it and lip-sync into it
and you have to have to sit there and
put up with this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
marimba music
oh my god it's a [ __ ] nightmare
listen when i met joe rogan he had a
whole
no no pop no head shot policy and i'm
like but
how are you not going to date actresses
they're hottie because you don't know
what comes with them
let me tell you something dave one of
those actresses you got your [ __ ]
hands full
everybody on saturday was like j lo and
for whatever broke up but let me tell
you something who gives a frenchman [ __ ]
worry about your relationship that's all
you got to worry about jlo broke up with
[ __ ]
a-rod go they probably got [ __ ] they
probably couldn't shoot steroids anymore
together that's how you think
she keeps her ass so [ __ ] big and hot
and juicy
by [ __ ] doing sit-ups yeah you bought
that [ __ ] line [ __ ] sucker
she's doing decka de roblin too but
anyway it's great to be here on a monday
[ __ ] great weekend with the family
again
[ __ ] comedy i ate a bag of dicks last
wednesday at uncle vinnie's but hey
it happens you can't [ __ ] go up there
all the time and just think you're gonna
sniff some nut sacks
and get out of there sometimes you gotta
swallow the whole soul
the whole sword and take it like a
[ __ ] man there's nothing you could do
about it you know what i'm saying
uh let me see what did i do i did two
guitar lessons this week
i've been practicing last night you [ __ ]
suckers and your [ __ ] guitar advice
you know i got an addictive personality
you know it and you're throwing videos
at me and joey do this
and joey listen to this [ __ ] thing
you guys are gonna [ __ ] put me in the
guitar [ __ ]
rehab people go to rehab for [ __ ]
cocaine and pills and reefer
i'm going to be the only half a [ __ ]
playing like a ukulele for 10 minutes
i have to wean off the guitar because
you [ __ ] suckers keep
all right listen i'm just getting
started the best thing about me getting
started with this guitar is it's not
like comedy
it's like anything else i got no
illusions or grandeur by the time i get
good
i won't even be able to [ __ ] hold the
[ __ ] thing i'll be like the guitar
player from motley crew
have you heard anything about the motley
crew ticket ticket tours
remember they were gonna do that big
tour with [ __ ] poison all those
people that [ __ ] ended
mick mars is 60 going on 90. he said he
can't even pick up the [ __ ] guitar
he's gonna have to have a little [ __ ]
hold it for him while he's stretched
[ __ ]
dr feel good you know what i'm saying
that you [ __ ] crazy
by the time i get any good i'm gonna be
[ __ ] a hundred so relax
that's what's great about this it's just
a stress reliever for me
it filled in the biggest void i had in
my heart
nighttime my wife leaves me at 9 30 the
baby goes to bed at nine
i sit down here i got two options shoot
heroin
[ __ ] watch more [ __ ] bad tv
or [ __ ] uh you know so i started
reading my books
i started [ __ ] playing the guitar at
night he gives me exercises
i learned ready for this one you ready
for this one i learned the first three
chords of back and black so i could play
bam bang
we'll save that for later you know what
i'm saying thank you that
we'll save that for later but the that
then
damn it i could do i'm not gonna play it
for you because it sounds like [ __ ]
something different but at least i'm
halfway there that's all that matters
you got to stick with it [ __ ] nothing
happens on the [ __ ] couch nothing
except you might find a nickel on there
from time to time and who needs a nickel
i got to check the update for 25 cents
from some movie i did 18 years ago
but i deposited [ __ ] yeah you don't have
to record as jewish
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna sit
here 25 cents gas is going up all of a
sudden
[ __ ] this guy becomes president i
move here it's 202.
two dollars and two cents for gasoline
new jersey i just got to go down a
little bit down there there's some
people
they look kind of weird i think they
they cut the gasoline
two thousand two cents it's 360 now all
over this i heard it's like five hours
in [ __ ] california who gives a [ __ ]
i don't live there anymore but you know
what it's monday
rejoice the blue is back i'm back uncle
joey's back
and as promised i switched it up on you
this week
every monday we're gonna have a guest
and every wednesday it's just one on one
so you don't think uncle joey's [ __ ]
being a gabon and giving everybody a
[ __ ] ear beat
hey sometimes we might switch it around
we might i might come on on monday we
might have a guest on wednesday but for
now it's been working out
and uh this week i got one of my friends
that
i have been a fan of his since about
2008
i really got to know him at the store
about 2013
and i considered him a younger brother
than me
and i could see that for a couple years
he had the world by the balls which
and something wasn't right so i always
made it a
uh a point to keep in touch with him
because i loved him dearly he's got the
heart of gold
he's from my home he's from my one of my
heroes hometown
pistol pete mavic she's one of the
baddest white [ __ ] that ever
lived behind tom brady
and a couple other white [ __ ]
that i love
and uh i've always loved this kid and
last week we were talking
and we finally figured out what was
eating away at us the last couple of
years
we were burnt out we were just burnt out
uh
it's very rough to do what we do
especially when you want to be as good
as you want we wanted to be you have to
constantly have material
your mind is constantly in thought
sometimes mike would call me and say hey
did you see this mike i don't even know
that's existing because
i'm too busy trying to write the tail
end of this [ __ ] joke you know
he was one of the guys that was working
alongside with me and uh
i don't give a [ __ ] when anybody has to
think i still think that
some of the best work i i always tell
you my best work
i think my special sucked i think the
work i did for ari
was great the this is not happenings
but looking back now today as a man i
have to be
proud of what we did with the church and
what's happening now
we did 880 episodes 400 of them probably
sucked
200 of them were probably okay and 200
of them were spectacular
i uh theo vaughn made one of them
spectacular because we all ate mushrooms
and then he went and did sets and people
didn't know he was on the mushrooms and
they taped them and
it was just a great podcast he told us
about his adventure in new york with the
cab and
i fell in love with the kid naturally
and then he became sober and he was
struggling and
listen man uh as comics
you have no idea what's on the other
side of the the mind of the comic for me
i'm not gonna sit here and tell you it's
depression and that [ __ ]
do i look [ __ ] depressed to you i'm
the happiest i've ever been
but when you're in it you're in it and
you don't know you're not really taking
time to smell the roses
and somewhere there's a disconnect and
that's what happened with a lot of
comics
and that's why now you're going to see a
lot of comics that yeah even though it's
been a year
they're going to take a little
additional time off and really really
get to the root of the [ __ ] matter so
uh without further ado
a little zoom on a monday with my man
theo vaughn i hope you enjoy it
suckers hey brother how are you today
michael
hey what's up to you oh [ __ ] huh jesus
oh [ __ ] it's the mack daddy of the mack
daddy's
what's up joey [ __ ] theo vaughn
looking good
come on looking decent let's don't
you got a nice haircut and [ __ ] let me
see
oh yeah you're looking all young and
[ __ ] the mullet's gone
yeah it is maybe there we go
let's do it huh where's lee man where'd
you guys bury lee
he's tough to bury you got to pick him
up and throw him in the hole i'm saying
you just got to burn that body that's it
throw leaves some [ __ ] gasoline and
oh [ __ ] ignite oh i got a buddy that
does in-ground pools we'll [ __ ] find
a spot for him baby boy
he's in florida he's doing great listen
the best thing that happened out of this
podcast was that we
got to find himself part of me doing
what i did was moving and i could have
brought lee
listen 78 of the people who live in this
town
have children under 18. oh my god man
like pedophiles you mean no they just
have kids under 18 in the house
this ain't a [ __ ] kid town if lee was
sitting in his room on studio city in in
laurel canyon and there was no action
can you imagine out here with trees and
beers and [ __ ]
no so he's he went to boston
he went to milwaukee got a job helped a
guy put together an app
he went to boston for a month and helped
his mom now he's in florida doing a
great patreon he lost 51 pounds
yeah yeah i watch him on his walk
sometimes he'll do these walks you know
and i'll watch him on there and i'll and
i'll
chime in and two and a half [ __ ]
miles three miles a day
and listen when i was 21 i had a really
good job
i was running numbers in the city yeah
and i was making 140 a day
but i also knew that that was going to
come to an end one day
i was smart enough even then when i was
all [ __ ] up and coked up
i knew that what happens when i'm 28 one
day
and i go for a job and they're like what
have you done the last 10 years
well i've been running numbers so when
you run numbers it's either you're
running numbers to open up a bank
eventually or you know you're just going
to be a numbers runner or your [ __ ]
life and
i had no money to open up a bank so
one day i picked up and left because i
knew
i needed to [ __ ] stretch my wings you
know i'm saying like i needed to find
myself and prove it to myself that i
could make it on my own
oh yeah when i started the podcast with
lee i thought he'd come to me five years
later you know look i started this
podcast this podcast
i started a business consulting i'm out
of here you know
i felt that lee would just he just uh
he got soft like i got soft we both got
soft you know we were caught in a
[ __ ]
carousel and look at him now
yeah he's living his life now deal he's
making it happen
he realizes he's 32 he's got to get a
piece of [ __ ] pretty soon
he's going to bust oh yeah uh he needs a
woman in his life
these are all the things that i couldn't
help him with that he needed to just
find on his own
that's what a man does they go on a
journey they go [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know
i could sit here in uh medford
[ __ ] uh louisiana where you're from
but i see mike
tasting different my waters from all
over the world
yeah go out there invention find out who
the [ __ ] theo von really is that's what
people need to do every once in a while
oh yeah sometimes you got to set down
kind of what's where you've been at it
and go
no i look yeah like i remember
i mean yeah like because look for me man
joey i
it was like you guys and fighter and the
kids was
there was only two podcasts and rogan
you know
and then um and then outside of that
on youtube it was just kimbo slices just
beating people up you know what i'm
saying there was nobody else out there i
remember
you know except for funerals i remember
i used to be able to watch
funerals online dude they got these uh
like not nairobian but like uh arabic
funerals or something dude like six
hours of [ __ ] funeral footage on
there there's no audio but it's still
you know
it's you know but anyway it's like um
yes
i remember then it was like you guys
were the only shows in town
man dude the church broke going in there
man you guys were
dude you remember the time so i come in
there one time bro i had to tell you
this
and good to see you today man i didn't
realize how much seeing your face was
going to make me so happy that's what i
said to you i go this is
i've been doing this the last three
saturdays with different comics
it's saturday right now we would have
been in a [ __ ] hotel room
thinking about our lives thinking about
the two shows tonight
who's going to go drawing pictures of
cocaine i used to draw pictures of
cocaine on the [ __ ] little pad by the
bed with the pen
you know how hard it is to draw cocaine
bro you know what i'm saying it doesn't
even make any sense but
um but dude i remember i came in when i
came in one time to the church
and in the beginning i said hey lee
there's like a squeal or something
there's like a high-pitched sound in the
headphones can you
you know you just check and figure out
what it is and so he's over there
tinkering and
we get into the episode i think we got
into a bag of mushrooms or something
about three hours later i hear the sound
again but i look over this time and it's
literally lee is unconscious like this
he's like
now he's making the sound in the
headphones in the beginning it was like
an actual electronic audio deficiency
and by the end
man he was just like a possum just
playing [ __ ] high
you know the [ __ ] drug abuse
the you know yeah i almost
one time i was leaving there i said i
got to take this guy to the [ __ ] vet
i said the hospital can't help this guy
bro
you have no idea that we grew
as the edible era group like we got into
the podcast
as edibles were [ __ ] like for years
it was the lollipop and the bread strip
and then we got on board and all these
[ __ ] places started coming up with
little edibles
and i'll never forget it started with a
black and white cookie
it was a company that made a black and
white cookie that was 200 milligrams i
would break it with lee and tell him it
was
15 milligrams and he would tell me this
has to be stronger than 15 milligrams
i'm building this tolerance i'm taking
chiba shoes out of the 170s
and putting 70 milligrams in there right
i'm taking the 70 milligrams and
taking them out and putting the 180s in
there
and i would i mean it was like stealing
i would
wrap it a certain way so he would know
that i actually [ __ ] with it
yeah and he would go i don't want that
one because you messed around with it
well he actually was taking the one with
the 180 in it
because i folded it perfectly and crazy
glued it and did the whole [ __ ] thing
i mean it was just
months and months that he thought he was
taking 10 milligrams
and he was taking 2 000 milligrams
we were leaving there just [ __ ] lit
people have no idea how many people
walked out of that room at the end
i saw ron white i mean
sarah tiara theo vaughn
poor owen benjamin was walking and
they're still [ __ ] walking
you know i mean it just it was
just a [ __ ] uh you know gabriel came
up the first time
for years gabriel wouldn't come back on
for years he said he left and he
couldn't stop eating turkey sandwiches
he said he went home
he must have ate 15 turkey sandwiches it
was just
and it was fun while we did it because i
listened to you i felt this
rogan was always very intelligent bill
burr was witty
i couldn't beat marc maron's interview
in styles
so for me to get up there i had to do
something from the outrageous so i
figured
we'll go out there with my strength
which is [ __ ] my tolerance
and we'll smoke dope and we'll [ __ ]
eat edibles and we'll do
ketamine and whatever a guest shows up
with
except [ __ ] blow i'll do in that
[ __ ] studio you know and heroin we
never did everyone on the podcast
i remember one time i dropped the butt a
pee of
reefer and pete i had it in my
sweatshirt
and the bud the the canister fell out of
my pocket
and the buds two buds went into the pee
and i took them out and saved them
and i saved them there for like two
months and i brought them in one night
and i rolled them up in a joint and
smoked them and he's like this part got
me really high tonight i
i don't know what it is i'm like you
know what it is it i dipped it in
[ __ ]
phc piss from the night before when my
piss levels at the highest thc levels
and that [ __ ] crusted on and
then we smoked that number
his eyes were ready he's like i can't
taste the pea i can't believe he made me
taste the banana
there's no p involved the p
disintegrated it went right into the
[ __ ] bud
it was too much it was just too much i'm
listening when i
when i decided to end that podcast it
was one of the hardest days of my life
but what happened to the studio joe the
studio i gave it up for rent
wow was it hard to do was it tough or
did you guys have a day where you moved
everything out or kind of
you know what what went down there what
was that day like was it just you was it
lee what happened
it was july 12th when
i made the official decision that we
were moving
and it took about four or five days to
think of what i was going to do with the
church
and i had a decision to make
i was either gonna leave lee which i
would miss him
tremendously or i would drag lee to
south jersey
and i took a look at the big picture i
was starting to get emails
for two years about that i was enabling
lee
and i was starting to feel guilty i was
starting to feel guilty because i felt
that
just like mike is helping me now i like
mike
and i like that he helps me i like that
he's here twice a week
but in three years i want mike to say
listen i'm i'm doing this
i'm doing this i'm doing this you know
i'm just giving
you a warning as a friend that maybe in
six months i want to take this in a
different direction would you mind and
i'm the type of [ __ ] that i want
to see people grow
you know i'm saying i'm the type of yeah
i'm cheering for you to grow that's
partly you know
i took my daughter to kickboxing this
morning oh yeah
and some little new kid got a white belt
and you have to clap for the kid
and on the way out i told my daughter i
go you know what they're teaching you
there when you're clapping for the kid
is for genuinely be happier for people
that's part of this whole thing that you
can't no jealousy we have to be
have to be happy for people and we have
to push people that are around us
up a little bit like you have an update
deal let's talk what's the matter i
don't know
my material theory you're gonna do great
don't think about what's going on
just go up on stage next thing you know
jeff scott rips calling theo up
and you go up there and kill and you
[ __ ] destroy i just lifted you i just
told you it's gonna be okay before we go
on stage that one minute before we go on
stage we get hit with every doubt that
we can in the world
every doubt you know all kinds of stuff
fly in my head i shouldn't be in the
same room with bill burr i went to
prison
i'm not a good joke rider this guy's way
better than me you know you get all
these doubts in your head then you got
to pick yourself up that's what i'm
there for
because for years i would look at that
stage and i know they're bringing me up
the lights on blue you know how many
nights i almost ran the [ __ ] out of that
like just
coming to the stage joey diaz awesome
and [ __ ] i'm running on sunset
stripping a [ __ ] car from fear
but no that's when i would sit there and
go [ __ ] this
i gotta go up there and [ __ ] kill
these [ __ ] period and that's
where you get your balls from you know
yeah i think i gotta remember remember
that sometimes too just to lift people
up and be a part of just like
you get into this space sometimes where
you get in fear where it's like
you don't even realize you're in fear
you're just trying to hold on to
everything you got going on you know uh
it's hard i mean it's all a little bit
tricky sometimes you know
when your career changes when you know
the
the landscape changes you know and uh
yeah it's just i mean it's a journey man
it's all a journey what does theo
think of his career today where's
theovan today with his career
well i feel you know when i really start
to drop into it i feel
i feel pretty good man i feel that you
know i feel honestly i hate to say this
i feel grateful for the [ __ ] disease
or whatever this thing is you know
uh whatever happened because i was kind
of burnt out man
like my brain felt like it like
separated from my neck you know like
somebody been [ __ ] feeding me knives
at night you know like i was just like
i was exhausted uh you know like about a
year and a half ago i cancelled i had
five
shows in brea that were sold out for
friday saturday
and i cancelled on a tuesday i couldn't
go on i just couldn't i was just burnt
i could just cook i literally could not
go out there and do it i was just burnt
out
so uh so i needed some type of a break
and this whole virus came along or
whatever it is
and so now i feel pretty i feel a little
more hopeful like i'm getting more
excited i was grateful to have
podcasting during that
you know like we've been at least able
to survive you know we've been at least
able to like
okay we got a microphone you got uh
michael over there we got sean over here
we got a producer okay how do we start
to piece this together
you know and week by week you start to
get your set back behind you when you
figure it out and
and then you start to really like okay i
think i can do this okay he can come in
on a saturday i can come we can do this
you know we start to build it back up
and
i'm starting to feel again like i can
get on stage again and it feels kind of
fun
you know like i didn't want to get on
stage for a year honestly bro
i just was just cooked um
and we did a lot man during that five or
six i don't know you you guys did it for
so long you guys fighter and the kids
um man you know you guys did it for so
long
but i just got into that wheel where it
was like three episodes a week and
and going out of town and doing the
shows on the weekend it just
it was like um i felt like a remote
control car you know but some
[ __ ] had the remote and we didn't
even know where he was you know
i felt like jesus who's got the damn
remote dude you know
i felt like some brother was on pcp and
he had [ __ ] happened upon the remote
you know like
my goose was [ __ ] grilled baby so
right now i feel like okay what do i
want to do
like it took me a long time to feel like
okay this audience is gonna stick around
like i felt like man like i think in my
whole life everything i always felt
like when i was a kid like i didn't know
if things were gonna stick around like
i didn't know if the next second was
guaranteed or if the next
you know if when my mom came home if she
was gonna feel okay or if she was gonna
be happy i just there was never any
guarantees you know so
i think it took me a while to feel like
okay
if you go sell a show in a year put your
name on a bill
in a year people are still going to come
and so that's what i'm just kind of
getting to i feel like personally like
having some confidence that
i don't have to fight every single
second for
somebody to be there that okay you've
done enough work
where people are gonna come you can
start to be a little bit more like come
from a place of
of like planning instead of a place of
like uh
desperation or reactiveness you know i
feel like now i can kind of take action
so yeah i want to maybe do some touring
later in the year and in the next
year um i'm working i got a cartoon i'm
thinking about trying to work on
i think about writing putting together a
book or something
um but man i didn't realize how happy
until just just this moment how happy i
am to be here with you today bro thank
you dog
uh theo let's go back to 2006.
i'm playing beaumont
you're doing some casino in new orleans
uh
i heard of your name you had done
something for mtv
or whatever when did
this hit you in the face that your
little [ __ ]
dream that we both had this little
thing started we started living it what
year did it start
going into motion for you
i guess that it started going into
motion i would say
you know
[Music]
i think there was probably a night i was
in kansas city man i was at a
at the funny bone there i think or
improv maybe
and i wasn't really selling any tickets
or anything
but i remember
the building was burned i was in a hotel
somebody set it on fire
right it's always a good sign
yeah yeah well it's i mean it depends on
what like religion you are but yeah some
religions maybe
but um so i'm there
and the firemen are coming up bro and i
just you know look i just got into my
room from the shows it's cold outside i
got a [ __ ] big sandwich but i'm
sitting there on the bed
if i die i die you know what i'm saying
i'm not [ __ ] leaving the hotel room
you know
and there's literally police officers
beating or you know whatever it is fire
police or whatever you know people with
the axe you know
i think it was a black guy honestly
right signing black i'm not saying that
but and look i would rather a black
fireman i believe a black guy could beat
fire
you know i don't know what your paper
rock scissors chart is but i believe if
you go brother fire bruh
i'll [ __ ] put a brother over fire
brothers don't like fires
you know what i'm saying it's in their
dna they don't like
for years on fire they just don't like
it a black fireman shows up that fire is
going down
that's what i'm saying is done you know
what i'm saying
brothers don't like fire him that
brothers and frankenstein they never
like fire
people chased them [ __ ] for
years with [ __ ]
yeah dude so i knew when i would be
canceled by wednesday you know
what are we gonna do handsomely son they
can't take nothing away from me bro
already what are you gonna do that's it
baby i hope they can't
we'll start a new show called [ __ ]
welcome to cancer baby welcome to
cancerville greetings from cancerville
that's it [ __ ] you [ __ ] kick
that mayonnaise lee you know yeah [ __ ]
it we'll
show up with a [ __ ] picture of
weinstein hanging on a rope
behind us and [ __ ] [ __ ] it somebody gave
me a car deodorizer
with wine hanging i don't know if i
should put it in my car i feel weird
i'm a catholic i can't have people
hanging around bad spirituals
yeah that's a reason around me that's a
risky move man but i remember
i remember they're beating on the door
bro they think i don't know why
you know it's a you know kansas city
it's still a smaller kind of city and so
i don't know if they think the fire's in
my room or whatever but they're beat
everybody else is evacuated from the
hotel you look out the window you can
see the flames downstairs you know on
the first floor
and i'm on like the 12th floor they got
me out at one of those landmark
hotels you know you're outside of the
city and
um they're beating on the door and i'm
not going anywhere
and that's kind of when i realized you
know what like
i'm not going anywhere you know i did my
shows i got a sandwich i'm sitting here
i'm at a [ __ ] i'm at the tallest
[ __ ] hampton inn in america you know
what i'm saying bro like
i don't care if they burn this [ __ ]
down i don't care if there's
fire if there's [ __ ] brother with
axes and [ __ ] buckets of water at the
door
i'm not going anywhere and i think there
was a little part of me in that night
that was like
just like this is it this is where
you're gonna be
man uh no matter kind of what happens
and i still felt like in my head at that
time and in my in my spirit i felt like
i was capable
and i knew i was doing a good
doing a good comedy show but nobody else
knew it yet
and that's kind of uh but but that's
when i felt like i was committed bro
when they're beating down the door you
know
and the brother was cool man he actually
came in they finally you know they came
in because they jimmy the [ __ ] open or
whatever eventually
you know i don't know if these guys also
do pop a lock or whatever during the day
but this [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying he was in there and
in about 10 in in about 10 seconds when
he was in there and
and he saw me and i said hey man i just
got back from work you know if
you know if they're if i'm really gonna
burn double back around and he said i
got you fam
and uh and it was i don't know it was
just kind of cool so that's when i knew
i was in
when did i know my career was gonna get
better honestly not to a podcaster man
not till you guys not to a fighter in
the kit man until i went on those
podcasts i didn't really have anybody
that cared
can you believe that for years we
got to la and they told us we had to
have a show
and you have to do this and you have to
do that and
next thing you know you go on somebody's
podcast and you tell a story about i see
mike or
how you got to drive your fault to
liquor store when you were a kid
and next thing you know there's 80
people
at your [ __ ] show that said they
really like what you
it was mind-blowing the growth of the
podcast
was a connection you know when i got to
l.a it was
get on a tv show recur on it and
get people guaranteed to come out yeah
tons of people on tv shows that
can't sell tickets now you know podcasts
legit
legitimized us it made us
put our money what our mouth is it told
you know for me it was telling the story
about mugging a hooker and lighting a
wig on fire
oh yeah the next week i'm out there and
i'm selling tickets
i had done adam sandler movies
spider-man 2
you know i did everything i [ __ ]
could except go to montreal they never
wanted me as a comic
so i went to the back door and look we
ended up going through the back door
because we were not from the comedy
central cut
where the [ __ ] are they play they're all
hiding for cover
because for 20 years they provided uh
services
that one out of five comics were [ __ ]
the real killers
they were giving you fluff and whatever
the [ __ ] they wanted to give you
so they lost credibility when all of a
sudden you and hari and
bert and [ __ ] tom and all these
comics that were unknown to the audience
and now became known comedy central lost
face
they're over there jumping up and down
with the three three same comics i have
nothing against them
nothing at all i love daniel taj i miss
going on the road because i would watch
the taj
one after the other one 2.0 whatever the
[ __ ]
loved that [ __ ] but it wasn't just tosh
they were giving half hours to people
you never even [ __ ] heard of
oh dude somebody didn't know they had
heard some guy in a coma they gave him a
half [ __ ]
hour dude he had like it was like eight
beeps one defibrillator went off because
the battery was low on it that was his
half hour yeah because he was
he was allegedly transgender we don't
[ __ ] know if he yeah
and comedy central was forcing these
comics down in your throat
the special were there on friday
saturday and sunday then
you'd move on and that was it now
you know when people come to see you let
me tell you the other problem was that
let's say you want a show that was like
uh
think of what's the guy that was coming
to the store that did america's funniest
videos
bob said bob sack you think of some guy
like bob saget that was on a family show
then you see bob saget talking golf and
watch him
talking about putting two fingers in
your [ __ ] and smelling your fingers
people were running out of those places
because they expected to see
the fatherly figure that was bob saget
podcast changed that
podcast let you know exactly who the
[ __ ] we were
and where the [ __ ] were you coming from
and if you don't want to come you don't
have to come you know
what's on my mind yeah that gave you
more of a personal touch that
people that have tv shows now i know for
a fact i don't want to drop any names
it's not for me to say
they can't sell tickets oh yeah because
that connection is not there now if they
would have done the
tv show and a podcast throughout the
week to contain that tv show
on their own not cbs run
with the co-star and you got to talk you
know but letting people what's on your
let people know what's in your heart and
soul not what some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] writers are writing for you
it would make a world of a difference
now to an actor
when that show moves on guess what
you're gonna
retain that audience and they're gonna
follow you for years for comic cons and
[ __ ] like that
but that's what i'm trying to say that
podcast
changed the game especially for guys
like you or me that had a life
that yeah yes yeah they had one of the
things we wanted to talk about
or also sometimes it's just things you
want to feel things you want to have a
concern about
you know it's like i can talk to you and
if i need help with something i can i
can
say it like even as we're talking about
hollywood man sometimes i feel bad
not bad but i like i get angry at
hollywood but i don't want to be
carrying that anger
around because hollywood's still a good
you know it just it's just a business
you know it's just their business and
it's sometimes it's an old model but
it's obviously a killer model you know
um
you know sometimes i guess i have this
chip on my shoulder about hollywood and
i wish i didn't have it sometimes you
know uh
because it doesn't do anything then i'm
just carrying this kind of angst you
know
um but yeah man i'm grateful
i would never be mad at you for having a
chip on your shoulder against hollywood
and i'm going to tell you why
one thing during this pandemic it gave
us all opportunity to think it also gave
us
a chance to get the opportunity to catch
up on
[ __ ] we hadn't seen you know you get
sick of what they're serving you on tv
so you start watching other things you
start watching movies that
same thing with music i started
listening to music i had listened to in
20 years i have the albums
i just listen to different stuff on
spotify and youtube when i'm on a
computer
i watched the movies that stuck out the
most when i
watched this was bronson's death wish
steve mcqueen's getaway which i watched
the other night
and i watched uh how the west was one or
something with charles bronson which was
a long ass movie and what i realized was
i was a fan of that hollywood i was a
fan of those
men how they conducted themselves you
know
when marin called me and said that artie
lang had fallen out for his episode
against sally struthers
i had a bunch of [ __ ] to do that week
but i didn't really care
i cancelled it and i did the episode
because i wanted to talk to sally
strutters about steve mcqueen in the
getaway
and i remember asking her at the third
day not the first to second day i had to
keep you know you can't be a
comedian act like a jerk well but the
third day your last day on the set
you could be a little bit of a jackpot
because you're not coming back tomorrow
anyway so i asked her
i go how is steve mcqueen and she goes
he was an animal
and i remembered why because in that
movie she's yelling in the hallway
he just looks at her and [ __ ] punches
her right in the [ __ ] face
like you couldn't get away they give you
22 years now
for doing that [ __ ] on film even you
can't do it on film but
that's the way i treated hollywood i i
went to hollywood i wasn't a formal
actor neither were you we did not go to
russia and learn for a year
or to some accredited whatever oh but i
could act in some ways i could act no
i've been acting at school when a
principal said you guys buying weed over
here oh yeah yeah you know me
you know me if you can use an agent's
credit card you could act you know what
i'm saying
yeah if you're gonna take my daughter
out for a night time yeah of course i am
sorry
if you're gonna if you can walk with an
apple store and walk out of there with
an ipad with
johnny woo's credit card that's acting
everything else that sucked my dick
you know shakespeare theater and all
that you can suck my dick ain't nobody
[ __ ] watching you
but it's it's it's really funny how
you know those are the style of guys i
liked sinatra
which meant that they were going to be
not
not bad guys on the set but they weren't
going to tolerate [ __ ] on this
outlaw do your [ __ ] takes and let's
move the [ __ ] on by the way everybody
wants to be johnny [ __ ] artist
with the little lens and they're seeing
something you're not you're not seeing
dick
and when we shoot the movie they're
gonna show 10 seconds of this and you
spend two hours on this [ __ ] thing
you know difficult on the set that's the
word i'm saying people
think it's difficult you know what when
i did comedy for
my question originally question for you
was when did it
when after 2006 when i saw you
with josh wolf and when did you move to
la
and when this realized that you were
living your dream
oh man i don't know if i
2012 let's just give it a shot
when did you move to la yeah i moved to
la in 2005 maybe 2004.
okay so about 2010 11 you already had
your netflix special
well yeah my netflix vessel came out
actually i think 2015.
15. okay and that didn't
what that didn't do that that didn't do
it
well it came out right but you were one
of the pioneers
and it fell between the [ __ ] things
it fell between you so it's really weird
that you said that and you're saying
this to an audience
it fell through the whatever nobody
really caught on to it
like you expected what caught on was
when you went on rogan
and told your stories everything changed
after that
then you came on with me and we did that
hash podcast the
the uh mushroom podcast where you went
to both places
and somebody obviously taped your sets
at both places and it became like a
[ __ ] thing
and you and i spoke last week just
checking in with each other
wednesday i go to uncle vinnie's and as
i'm coming on stage my friends are there
i talk to them
i'm walking towards the car and some kid
walks over and he goes how's theo doing
and i'm like looking at this kid
and he goes i gotta tell you i listen to
a lot of podcasts i drive a truck and i
load trucks
the one you did with theo with the
mushrooms
that's so far one of my all-time
favorite podcasts and i just go i can't
believe you said that to me because i'm
gonna have a podcast with theo next
monday so
there you go you're a [ __ ] mind read
and i always felt that i always felt
that
10 years from now when they look at
those podcasts
we're the cutting people like the
lucille balls we like the black and
white
podcast like when you look at our
podcast it's gonna be like black and
white like we were the
old school [ __ ] no real studio
just a sheet thrown up against the wall
and then in time we got better
and better and better and we got a
studio and we put albums up and it
looked like something substantial
it's just so weird to see the growth and
now i'm doing it again
at the joint and i'm and i told people
from day one i wasn't ready to do this
and because of covid it's tough to get
guests it's tough to trust people
it's tough to compromise other people
who are in the room like mike has
children and whatnot
on my own and then we have zoom you know
and uh
once i did the podca i i [ __ ] hate
zoom
i [ __ ] hate it you know because i
think it takes away that personal touch
that you and i have it removes it
but i also feel that if you have a prior
relationship with somebody
the zoom works a lot better i have seen
that so
yeah the part i miss is coming into your
studio dude if you're already sitting
down i got to go around you to get into
my seat you know
right so what i love is we're always
kind of leaning in on your back and just
putting my arms on you
you know letting you know i'm happy to
be there you know
you let you know i love you you tell me
you love me and it always feels good man
i
you know that's a one little thing i
miss bro i
i so one thing people don't know about
the mushroom
show is so i rolled out of there
late bro i was supposed to be early on
that show
and i'm freaking i get in my car dude
and i see all the dashboard lights and
my car ain't even on yet
like [ __ ] man i'm on some mushrooms you
know
that's when you know your own mushrooms
do when the street lights are on but
they're not even on yet you're like damn
i'm seeing a lot of extra electricity
you know a lot of free electricity from
god
so anyway i get did i get over there
i get over there and i remember walking
down the hallway and shaking somebody's
hand and i felt like they took my hand
and i'm like [ __ ] bro i'm not you know
i'm feeling pretty squirrely if if i
feel like i shook somebody's hand and
they took my hand with them when they
walked off
so i said you know i'm having some weird
feelings right now but um
so the the set at the improv was crazy
but then
i went to the comedy store and that's i
think when the
the vegetables started to rattle inside
of me because
i get over there and i go on stage and
adam he gets over there and he's worried
about something you know he's just
[ __ ] hebrewing out over there you
know the [ __ ] living legend
of him eager he's [ __ ] concerned or
whatever you know and
so i just tell him everything's gonna be
okay get over there
get on stage and some guy near the front
was in a um
what's that thing called it's like if
you're handicapped but it's like a
little sh not like a it's like they push
you it's like a [ __ ]
we'll check up legit will challenge
wheelchair yeah yeah sorry wheelchair
yeah he's in a wheelchair yeah
wheelchair wheelchair so
this guy's in a wheelchair and it has a
little squeak on it bruh and i'm
[ __ ] you know someone when you're on
mushrooms some sounds are amplified and
[ __ ] so i'm on stage
and the wheelchair makes a little squeak
and i thought
somebody was making a funny noise and
making fun of me that's where my head
went
so i start so i stopped my joke i said
what would you say man i said i just got
in this negative place and the guy's
just laughing this guy could barely you
know
the last muscle he got working is his
throat muscles and he's [ __ ]
chuckling with him you know what i'm
saying this dude's
90 to heaven you know it's dude he got
nothing bro
but for some reason whenever he laughed
it made one of the like nuts or bolts in
the wheelchair wasn't tight and made it
squeak
and when i heard that squeak i thought
somebody was saying something and making
fun of me
so i kept stopping the show and like
accusing this wheelchair guy or
something and this guy could barely
[ __ ]
this guy couldn't get a mouth full of
milk down if you gave him two and a half
hours you know what i'm saying like
and i just keep roasting this dude and
ripping into him
and it was thank god that set isn't on
recording because that [ __ ] went
downhill fast
it's basically from half hour but you
pulled it off
yelling at a [ __ ] nom rescue guy bro
it was bad man
i [ __ ] went to ralphie mae's
thanksgiving party like
2007. right before i stopped going to
the store
ralphie may was on top of the world and
he [ __ ]
threw a barbecue that was tremendous
and on top of the counter before the
[ __ ] food was a bag of mushrooms
a pound of mushrooms and only three of
us
ate them me ralphie and marilyn martinez
got arrested so late like two of them
me and ralphie kept eating them in
between turkey bites
and she's still alive guys she just
tripped really hard so that's why
she [ __ ] died but not from my back
but uh [ __ ] i went down the store
you know it was thanksgiving i was gonna
cancel
like when you're having a good time
you're like [ __ ] the store the quarter
to 11. i'm not going there oh yeah
and in those days i wasn't getting
quarter to 11 spots i was getting 115
spots but it's thanksgiving
so the stars don't call in so a guy like
me gets
[ __ ] 10 45 you're like [ __ ] ready
i [ __ ] went down and as soon as i
walked in that original room
everything turned purple all i saw was
purple
and i just did as much time as i could
and i think after nine minutes i just
ran the [ __ ] out of there
it just turned purple everything in the
room was purple though i could hear the
neon light sizzling and [ __ ]
yeah yeah jeff's trying to play the
piano and improv with me i'm looking at
him like he's a [ __ ] martian from
another planet i'm like this is too
[ __ ] much
i could deal with the edibles and [ __ ]
but this mushrooms at this and then in
those days you gotta remember there was
only 18 people on a thursday
it wasn't no 3 000 people yelling your
name clapping
blue cheese and wings go [ __ ] your
mother i'm up there die in a slow debt
and everybody's [ __ ] purple i'm like
this is not normal
this is not going to continue my career
is not going places
i could handle edibles up there i could
not
you know what listen i got into comedy
july
16th and 91 and this weekend saint
patty's day
1992 i was cute and i went down in the
headliner had a reputation for doing
coke
so i bring i figured i'd bring a package
with me to try to be cool so the
headliner would hire me for other gigs
dog i started doing bumps at the
headlines this guy was an animal he
could do an ounce and [ __ ] go talk
for two hours like nothing happened and
remember punch lines
i went up there stuttering you should
have heard me i was like [ __ ] spider
in good fellas
i said never again well i'd do a line of
coke and get on stage so i learned early
on not to do coke and get on stage i've
never done lines
i'm a coke fiend yeah i had it in my
pocket when i went on stage i'm not
gonna lie to you many or not at the
store
i was on pocket but i was in uh on stage
with a coke pocket burning in my pocket
you could see the [ __ ] light coming
out of my pocket but i wouldn't do it
until i walked off the stage and in
those days i used to go right down those
steps
right into the original room bathroom do
do bumps
then i was ready to talk to people how
you doing all right yeah
good to see you all right dude
yeah i got on stage a couple times man
uh on coke and i it was
so hard to do
dude i remember when i i remember some
guy in college came out with a um
or he said he is you know a buddy or
something he was chinese i don't know if
he was chinese but he was
something was going on with him and he
said that they came out with like a uh
cocaine suppository right this is when
you know people were excited about
cocaine and you're like well
you know i'll try it however i can get
it you know and so i remember putting
putting one of those in my ass as a
college kid you know
and trying to do it different ways man i
just wanted that buzz in my system you
know and it burned the inside of my ass
i remember
and it was not uh it wasn't you know it
wasn't usda approved or whatever you
know
but um but anyway man i remember the
other worst time i've ever had on
cocaine outside of that chinese time was
when
i was on stage at the comedy store
and that was the worst if you were
buying coke you wanted the coke guy to
get there
after you're set bro cause if you got
there before
you got your coke you're like oh i'll
save my coke but you can't save your
coke bro
you know you can tell your coke i'm
gonna save you but then your coke's like
no you're not
and you [ __ ] gotta do a little to
make
sure you're to make sure you still know
how to do it you know
so i would do a little go on stage and
then like
i couldn't get the timing right of the
oh i i would be too quick on the punch
line and my chest
felt small and i felt scared the whole
time bro
that's one thing i i don't like about co
like
i just wish i if i was a tougher guy i
could handle
i think you got to be a [ __ ] cocaine to
me it's so strong that i i
can't meet it halfway sometimes you know
it just
it takes me over i you almost got to be
like [ __ ] rocky marciano and meet it
halfway
you know let me tell you something about
cocaine the cocaine's great
when you're trying to put some chick
together you're trying to have a good
time and you're trying to have a long
conversation with yourself but the
problem with cocaine and comedy is this
i wish prior was alive today so i could
ask him
maybe i'm wrong for me when i did coke
the night after i did let's say i did a
[ __ ] snow storm on a friday night
and i went on stage on saturday and i
still had coke in my pocket and i hadn't
done it
i could blow up a room no i'm lying to
you i could have a great set
joke wise what am i saying joke wise
straight from the notebook right from my
memory
straight from my mouth to you set up
punchline
you're gonna laugh it's gonna detour
that when you say a joke for a joke to
really connect it's gotta detour through
your heart
and through your soul the cocaine
detaches that soul
and heart that's why you feel mechanical
yeah
that's why you feel very mechanical you
know
it's bad enough you ever do three shows
in the night
oh yeah the old school improv 7
9 11 or 12 midnight madness or whatever
by the time you did midnight madness you
didn't even just know what jokes you
were saying
yeah because you're like did i say this
already didn't i say this already
you felt disconnected when you got off
stage you would always say i'm not doing
that [ __ ] midnight joke anymore i
never midnight showed anymore
because it too much on you and you
disconnected
because you you just did two shows and
you don't know what
the [ __ ] you said on both shows what
order
you now the third show you're sitting
there going i said that already no that
was the
third no i said that the second show
[ __ ] it
i'm not doing this show no more well
that's the same way it was
with cocaine with me oh yeah but for a
joke to work they got to feel it
through your emotion you have to become
vulnerable it's got to go through your
soul your heart and then your mouth your
brain
when the cocaine's in there it don't hit
your soul or your heart
you just become a [ __ ] uh person who
writes great jokes
and just says them like a computer yeah
you know that's a great that's a great
way to explain it man yeah that's the
way it felt
for me that's why i used to get pissed
off
when people would say [ __ ] about
lawrence taylor yeah he's a great
football player he's on coke half the
time let me tell you something when i
went to prison
i would do a line on speed on monday
nights and play basketball oh my god i
was horrible
my heart would be beaten out of my chest
i couldn't focus
so i think people were wrong about
lawrence taylor but years later he did
say he did it and went on the field then
blah blah blah
so who the [ __ ] knows how's your life
now in nashville visiting going back and
forth
between california yeah i mean i i came
over here to spend time in nashville
because
uh because
you know let me i'm going to say this
about cocaine too because since
we're just talking about i just because
you had me thinking about it that's a
great way to explain it man yeah it
takes away
it detaches you from like the real
emotions that are connected
to whatever you have going on so if you
see somebody you care about you don't
treat them the same way everything no
matter what if you have a job you care
about you don't treat it the same way
yeah it takes your emotions off it's
like uh
it's like a something that kills like
glue kind of you know cocaine
is when you look at it from a [ __ ]
distance now
from 13 right for me no
it's great when you're [ __ ] getting
your dick sucked and you're flying doing
somersaults with
you know when you're gambling you're in
vegas whatever
yeah but when you really look at the big
picture and when
when you figure out what you're trying
to do as a human being
when you're doing cocaine you're adding
evil into your life
if you really really really think about
it
it's a certain evil that you feel that's
why you're
you're tormented i'm not gonna do ever
do that [ __ ] again
and you quit for a week and you start
again now you're in that vicious cycle
and it's tormenting you and it tormented
me for years you know like i told
somebody
they listen i quit a thousand times and
finally one day it stuck
you know you got to keep quitting you
got to keep quitting and telling
yourself
i'm going to [ __ ] quit and then three
days later [ __ ] it i'm quick
i quit after thanksgiving you know what
i'm playing then yet
three days later i quit at the
thanksgiving after christmas
i said it so many times that after one
day it [ __ ] stuck
so i became becoming a comic and i could
put my emotion into my work
and years later i could see the
differences
of who i was on tape you know i could
feel it so
well i think it's so painful for some
people you know and some of us that have
had
childhood trauma emotional trauma in our
life
it's painful to stay attached to the
world to keep
to have your feelings stay attached to
things it's painful and so i think
that's probably
you know there's some elements of
cocaine when you're you know when you're
at college and [ __ ] where it's fun when
you're in your 20s where it's just a
good time
but there's also it starts to become
that thing that
makes you feel detached it makes you
you know it kind of like it's like a
fire extinguisher for the connection
between
you and things that you care about you
know because
when you have you know when you grow up
having a lot of trauma or something that
it's scary to stay attached to things
you care about because you feel like
they're gonna go or they're gonna
disappear you don't even realize it in
your head but in your spirit your
spirit's just so scared to stay attached
to things
that are good and so cocaine comes along
and it [ __ ] puts a little wedge in
between there
and it's almost like a little bit of
relief you know but uh
but the long term yeah it's it's rocky
man ever since i stopped doing coke i
realized i love my friends more i love
my wife more
hey man i loved my cats more i had a cat
i had nine cats
oh yeah and i had a cat named [ __ ] like
the man from st
ives [ __ ] was a beautiful [ __ ] cat
[ __ ] lived in my house for five years
and never would have contact with me oh
damn
she would come five feet of me and that
was it
i stopped cocaine a week later [ __ ] was
sitting on my lap
amen what does that [ __ ] tell you and
we you know after that we became tight
till she died two two
three years ago wow it was just really
weird she could
that's when i knew i didn't know at the
time when
i first had her i just thought she was
skittish my wife fed her
she liked my wife moreno i quit doing
coke and
a week later she's sitting on my lap
watching [ __ ] tv
it's weird nashville you like it
yeah one thing that's nice well first of
all
you know california was so shut down you
couldn't do nothing i mean
you come to nashville do whatever you
want dude you know what i'm saying you
got people you got inside you got
whatever you want going on over here you
know
you couldn't catch cove if you was
dating your [ __ ] sister over here you
know like
they just don't have it you know because
you know because
it's just not as i don't know that it's
not as afraid over here you know people
are just living their lives and shit's
pretty normal you got the jiu jitsu gym
is open
how'd you get to going i'm so [ __ ]
proud of you look at you what school are
you going to
let's go which school are you going give
them white help
what is it oh it's called nashville mma
okay and what's the guy's name who runs
it the guy's name over there named chris
the guy's name over there mr hammond's
this other guy named uh
irv this other guy named etai
and this other guy named andrew what's
chris's last name
um i don't know his last name i think
he's friends with a broadway i think
that's the guy but send them my love
how's jiu-jitsu working out for you
i will so many of the guys over there
ask about you man uh
it's good man i had to fight a child the
other day which was a little bit
you know it's a little i'm not a look
it's good to know you're not a pedophile
bro that was one nice part about it it
was like look
at no point during the thing was i like
doing this
yeah i said yeah i might enjoy it i was
like this is just technical you know
what i'm saying like i didn't feel any
like
hey let's go another [ __ ] you know
put nine minutes on the clock you know
so that was good
but it's a lot of like um right now i'm
still learning like a lot of like how to
approach like whenever you're like
approaching with somebody
it's a lot of defense you know but i
love it man i love just like
i love just defending myself and it just
makes me feel like
a little less scary about conflict or
not even conflict but just
interaction like getting too close to
somebody whether it's
to fight or to love it's always hard for
me bro it make
all of it scares me getting close to
people scares me bro
and so to have this thing that like
you kind of learn to fight and the love
at jiu jitsu because
if you find good people to roll with
then they're teaching
they're helping you learn how to fight
but they're doing it in a loving way and
so it's like
god bro it's like um i didn't realize
that it's exactly what i need
uh it's exactly what i need it's like
the opposite of cocaine man did it fill
that void for you that you've been
missing the last few years i think it is
i think it will the more i can focus on
it i think it will so i've been trying
to make more time in my life to be able
to focus on it and go the hard part
is i got to be flexible enough to even
go to the class
i got to make sure that i'm taking you
know i'm doing a little bit of yoga two
or three times a week
to get in there and just not break my
neck you know not just get
you know i gotta i gotta prep myself
before i go in there because a lot of
the people in there is younger and
there's children and they're fighting
you know
so it's um it's a learning process man
but it's so much cooler than i ever
thought and like
yeah man it's just fun you get in there
and everybody beats you and it's cool
and uh you're not getting in there
you're just a dumb guy in the back
yeah yeah that's why i used to just say
i'm not joey i'm just a fat [ __ ] in the
back sweating
i'd sit all the way in the back and i do
my little hip escapes and push-ups
and then sometimes i feel confident i go
up the line land number three
but for the most part i'm all the way in
the back i'm the fat dummy in the back
sweating it's smelling like onions and
[ __ ] garlic feet and [ __ ] and
toenail polish uh dude they got me
fighting a blind guy dude they got a
blind guy over there this guy is
probably
that one he's probably deadly you're
like jesus
if you weren't blind that [ __ ] take
your eye out already [ __ ]
you got me in an armbar and you're
[ __ ] blind no [ __ ] touching
when you wrestle him he's gotta have
little dots on this thing
you're the [ __ ] that makes the
governor stand next to him
he's probably the guy that stands next
to the governor giving out [ __ ] sign
language
all right let me tell you something if i
see one more sign language guy
everybody's got a [ __ ] sign language
assistant oh it's crazy
where's the bodyguard nah they got some
guy teaching your [ __ ]
line to you by the hands you're gonna
get your vaccine by tuesday no you're
not
you gotta do this [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
that's what that's that's what that
mulch
is that's the bad one bro creed rocky
that's why you got to watch the rocky
series i learned how to speak deaf
people language
[ __ ] it and sometimes it's not even
it's not even a it's not even a death or
sometimes this is a third base coach
that play that [ __ ] used to coach in
toronto you know he's nobody to [ __ ]
give him signals dude he used to go to
alberto cranes
and they used to put me against two
people a 74 year old guy
that by the way would [ __ ] me up his
name is the savage
go on youtube and type in savage bjj
he's 74 years old
don't type in savage bj though
savage bj you might get somebody else
you know what i'm saying
so you would fight this guy no name 74
years old
he would get there at 8 30 in the
morning with a cooler listen to me
not that [ __ ] construction cooler i'm
talking about a cooler
filled with liquids and protein powders
and carrot juice and gorilla biscuit and
menthol
nine o'clock he does the [ __ ]
kettlebell class 10 o'clock he does the
nogi class
11 o'clock he wrestles with the dummy by
himself
and at 12 o'clock he would do the
[ __ ] g class
and the upmost respect for him the guy
would stay there eat a banana
yogurt almonds he would he would do four
classes 74 years old and he would burn
bully you to death
he would [ __ ] one time he had my toe
because he's 74 so he goes to the simple
things you know what i'm saying
you're not going to grab your [ __ ]
arm you're going to pull him he'll do
like a toe thing
one time he got me the funky toehold
that's an old brazilian [ __ ] toehold
if you got to jam
this [ __ ] was killing me and
then there was a chick
like a brown belt that he was 50
i was probably 52 at the time 53
she was 56. i think i used to time it
like today i'm if i could last a minute
with her
i did good yeah she was heavyset
she would [ __ ] me up and then she would
need a belly me
ah she would stick her knee in my belly
my dick would pop up like a [ __ ]
like like that's how deep she would
[ __ ] just
he would press something like liverpool
there's a button in your stomach but if
you're pressing your dick gets hard i
mean
you learn so many things but you learn
that uh
you learn technique oh yeah it you
it's your comedy when you get back on
stage after a while it's going to go
back
to a level it's never been because
you're going to learn that
in jiu jitsu no matter what he does
you got to keep retrieving your guard
right you got to keep putting them back
in your guard then you could start
operating again you go for the arm you
go for the [ __ ] uh
kimora you can do all that [ __ ] but
the same thing with comedy when i would
find myself lost on comedy
i would take a couple breaths and i
would get find my home again which is
the closed guard
and then i would attack from there let
me get this on let me pull so he thinks
i'm pulling but i'm really gonna get him
with a scissor sweep
it's very interesting i'm very happy you
got into it brother and you know it's
crazy because
for four years you and i have been
having discussions that something was
missing from our lives we had comedy
we had podcasts we had everything we
wanted that's why i tell people be
careful what you want for because it
might just happen
you know and we got what we wanted but
there was always something missing
and you and i had this discussion last
saturday on the phone
for you it was the burnout process
yeah you were burnt out and now in
hindsight
i don't want to say it because my
personas to be a [ __ ] you know
hold on i was also burnt out but i
wasn't burnt out on the stand-up comedy
i was burnt out on the business side
i was burnt out on the the numbers and
the [ __ ] theaters and what the
theaters were charging you
and it never ended it never ended it
never [ __ ] ended so
it took away that love that you have to
stand up like that natural [ __ ] love
everything
was based on money you know i want to go
i want to be able to go to the pizza
parlor down the corner
and sign up for the open mic and be
number eight and get off
yeah when i'm able to do that that's
when i go back on the road for [ __ ]
comedy
when i could go to an open mic and do it
not for money it got to be for money and
i didn't like it for money anymore
yeah i want to fall in love with it
because i'm in love with it not because
you're paying me
a certain amount of [ __ ] money yeah
i don't i want to do anything in my life
for that
once you get over a certain age you
realize it's not the money
it's what makes you happy and what keeps
you happy while you're doing it
yeah no look i i think uh and i think
that's one thing joe that
that uh during this whole um
disease or whatever that people have
realized a little bit like
what am i doing on this on this ferris
wheel and this money go round like
who am i trying to put like i'm not
doing i'm just working for somebody
doing this for there's no like where is
my reward as a human where is my
value as a person like what is this rat
race you know like i think a lot of us
are like
you know i don't have to do all of this
i can slow my life down i can tell
people know and enjoy my life with my
children or my family or
you know we don't have to you know we
got you got everybody in the world
thinking that they can buy a yacht one
day or something watching all this gary
varner check online and [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] you know you could have a
[ __ ] uh
monte carlo you know like [ __ ] you
probably can't you know
you might be in a [ __ ] ford escort
the rest of your life
but it's about the other side of the
coin is just enjoying the time in the
ford escort you know like
why am i on somebody else's schedule all
the time
you know like we got i think hopefully
we turn in a little bit more like spain
you know they take a break after lunch
you know
that's good you know it's weird that i
also got sick of the making plans to do
comedy
and then something pops up socially
that you would really like to do yeah
you know like you would really like to
do that socially [ __ ] and you can't
because you have a date in [ __ ] des
moines
and you don't want to disappoint them
you don't want to cancel nobody but the
good thing is brother
we're three-quarters past is pandemic uh
we all made our decisions on where we're
going to end
up and what we want to do you obviously
did which makes me [ __ ] happy by
talking to you
i obviously did i'm going to finish my
shows at vinnie's
and i'm taking the [ __ ] summer off to
the sopranos comes back
the movie gets released to many saints
in newark and then
we'll evaluate and take it from there
but i'd also
love for you to stay in touch with me
and let me come on your podcast
yeah i'd love that bro we could talk
about i see mike and finish up today i
know your producer had plans and you've
got plans
it was just a saturday afternoon checkup
with you brother
you know to let you know i love you uh
we
we made history at the comedy store and
we know we made history on the podcast
with [ __ ] eating the mushrooms
you weren't even there the next night
was the night rain in bosnia was on
and when we ate the mushrooms again as
lee and dean were walking out
[ __ ] lee just barfed all over his
shirt
thank god we had extra shirts and he
kept telling me he was like
he would be okay and i'm like you're
okay lee and he would look at me and go
don't take me to the hospital i'm
it's gonna be all right don't worry
ladies we'll be lucky if we get you a
[ __ ] hot towel
brother no hospitals we gave him a
different shirt we threw his pukey shirt
away
and that was the video from lee from
outer space that was
that was that way before that what
nights are you going down to zany's
uh i don't i got i got a show there i
think on the 23rd or 25th
um i've been taking it real easy man you
know
and if i'm back in la i'll do a night or
two over there mark cyritella has a show
mark hayes
irish mark that guy send them my love he
took good care of me he was always
straight with me on the shows and
uh oh yeah he proved to be a gentleman
that [ __ ] dude
so yeah agreed man alex here tell us a
jeep but so is marquez man good job good
guys uh
but man i love you man i appreciate you
always checking in with me man and i'd
love to have you on the podcast soon and
and yeah it's like i'm just yeah man i
didn't realize how much i needed just
this conversation
i told you that i've been telling all
these older cats that we talk all the
time
on the phone and go listen i'm going to
give you a call
next couple weeks we're going to do a
face to face just to see each other just
to remind ourselves
of what we went through and that we're
gonna be all right
everybody's gonna be all right the
people that watch us everybody i wish us
all but thank you thank you to your fat
you what's the story when i see mike you
call him lately
oh i haven't seen him i've been back to
the neighborhood in a while dude they
had a flood in our area
so i'm sure he's probably doing well
dude you know what i'm saying if he's
collecting rare
water because i know i donated to
somebody's gofundme from that area
when it happened about two months ago
somebody reached out and said
can you bring it up on the podcast and i
forgot so i just threw something in a
gofundme phone
i don't know oh that might have been
houston maybe i don't know it was like
the city of or something like that
it's all good man dustin poirier doing
the diamond baby i know huh how exciting
for him so what
now you could train little jiu jitsu up
by you when you go home
go by dustin's and he'll clean it up for
you well he told me he'll fight me in a
gee one day if ever if i get a little
bit better you know and guys like dustin
oh my god you go three minutes of time
and it's a [ __ ] year education
oh i can imagine you got shortcuts they
got everything they do you know what i'm
saying it's like
it's like an open micro and then there's
us we've been doing it for 20 years we
got shortcuts we got ways to teach
with him he's going to just as you roll
along
he's going to be saying put your hand
here watch pull this in a little bit oh
[ __ ] i never even saw that and then he
opens up avenues for you that you don't
see
but that's why i like jiu jitsu because
it opened up so many avenues in your
head that it opens up avenues
when you're writing when you're on stage
so that's great that you have him
i can't wait to see you rolling with
dustin and [ __ ] and yeah maybe one day
man
dude i can't believe it took me so long
to get into jiu-jitsu i didn't realize
it was like just
it's not even about becoming like a
great fight or anything it's just about
no just being with yourself just being
with yourself i just picked up the
guitar i took my first two guitar
lessons last week
oh so look out for conway diddy uncle
joey
pretty soon and [ __ ] don't get me
started
i'm i am the most scared i've ever been
if you thought i was scared before i
took the pain pills
you'd be more scared now because playing
the guitar is an addiction that i knew
was gonna feed
like last night i went in there in the
afternoon and played and last night i
went back in that 12 30 i got to knock
this off
yeah but you know what if it [ __ ]
makes you happy
it can't be that bad cheryl crow 1999
you know what i'm saying
robert bro you better [ __ ] keep me
posted
uh got everything and i'm happy you made
the same decision i
did that we were just burnt out
yeah we we okay we did a [ __ ] job
you know these [ __ ] guns and roses
they go on tour for a hard year and then
they disappear for a year david lee roth
when he was at van halen with this a
[ __ ] pier no phone you couldn't even
get a hold of him
dave what do you think about this lyric
uh the number you call has been
disconnected
that's what i think about that [ __ ]
lyric go [ __ ] yourself i'm up here in
the himalayans
right off condoms and [ __ ]
i love you buddy thank you very much
have a great week thank you for coming
on the joint
stay black oh
what'd you think a little chat with our
buddy nice and easy on a monday morning
what the [ __ ] did you get to lose
nothing you learned about us we giggled
a little bit we laughed a little bit
and that's what mondays are all about
setting up the rest of the week
with a positive tone and [ __ ] making
it work that's it that's why i come here
man i love doing this [ __ ] for you guys
i love doing this
i'd rather do this right now and do
anything else in the world so look at
look at the first episode of this and
look where we are now
we've grown and if you've been paying
attention we've grown together
and that's the most important thing i
want out of this podcast
i'm not looking for laughs anymore i'm
not reaching for the [ __ ] stars
i'm looking a lot better i'm healthier
i'm recovering from a surgery
and i'm just being a [ __ ] dad i hope
you like what we're doing now what we're
trying to
accomplish here i love you [ __ ]
with all my heart wednesday night
i'll be at vinnie's the next three
wednesday nights and uh
that's it and that's that i hope you
enjoyed the uh the theo vaughn
segment and i hope you enjoy what we're
trying to do here
and i hope you're seeing the growth guys
i love you [ __ ]
and now for a word for my [ __ ]
sponsors stay black love you
all right you bad [ __ ] a nice
little monday morning
chit chat with cleo like i said these
things that i'm doing
with uh these comics that i haven't seen
for a long time even they say it it's
great to see each other because
it's been nothing but phone calls and
we'd have to we'd have to resume
to zoom anyway so it's been great i feel
better about my monday
and i hope you're [ __ ] all fired up
about your [ __ ] monday
it's gonna be a great week saint patty's
day
be careful with your beers you don't
want to get dosed and end up getting
[ __ ] in the ass
next to some guy we covered in the hotel
room in the hospital room you know what
i'm saying
so be careful with saying patty's day
but enjoy yourself but before that
let me talk to you about something the
joint is brought to you by manscaped
like i said in the beginning it's
tournament season you're right you want
to what you want
balls are going to be everywhere you
look right now
okay and to avoid the upset you got to
trim your ball scout
your ball sack with manscaped the
trimmer is the real [ __ ] champ
of this [ __ ] tournament the lawnmower
3.0
oh [ __ ] the best criminal to man
the only ball trimmer with that advanced
skin safe technology
that won't nick or snag your nut sack
you got to protect those little [ __ ]
jewels
and now when you get manscaped you're
also helping give back the testicle
that this killer cancer society and
they're supporting their families
and their survivor listen all jokes
aside
manscape wants to save all the balls
particularly the balls of guys
from 15 to 35 or most at risk
so this comes from from your uncle joey
take care of your balls
for [ __ ] science sake take care of
them the [ __ ] nuts say
but for starters get some manscape they
got it all listen you might as well get
the complete package
you know why it comes with the [ __ ]
lawnmower 3.0
it comes with the weed whacker for your
[ __ ] nose so the covert don't stick
in your [ __ ] nose hairs
you want to keep your nose where his
passages clean
it comes with the crop preserver it
comes with the crop reviver
and the little crop ball mop ball wipes
they're tremendous
plus they have the [ __ ] weed whacker
for your nose like i told you now
manscaped evens off as a [ __ ] cologne
so your neck smells like your balls so
you swap and spit
she smells your neck she's like wow he
smells good
now she's sucking your pipe and she's
like well boy his balls
match his neck this is a conscientious
man this
is who i want to be my husband uncle
joey's saving balls
and manscaping saving balls and i'm
telling you right now
go to manscape.com right now get the
[ __ ] performance package get it all
the crop preserver the crop reviver the
crop ball might
the [ __ ] weed whacker and the [ __ ]
uh lawnmower 3.0 right now today
i'm gonna give you 20 off plus free
shipping
at manscape.com joey again
that's manscape.com joey it's march
check your [ __ ] balls boys the joint
is also brought to you by listen
uncle joey's saving you money and making
you money
and taking care of you who else does
that what on the [ __ ] spot
one of the [ __ ] podcasts does that
now i'm giving you an opportunity
to make a little [ __ ] getus listen
you're gonna bet four bucks on an
underdog
if they win you're gonna win 256 dollars
uncle joey was a [ __ ] underdog and i
went off at 64 the [ __ ] one odds
would you bet me no you wouldn't don't
make the mistake twice this is [ __ ]
madness
and it's all going down at draftkings
this is the biggest college tournament
of the [ __ ] year and you're sitting
there with your hemorrhoids on the bench
like a [ __ ] mama luke
you bet four dollars for the underdog if
they win
you went up to 256 [ __ ] dollars
all it takes is four bucks to get a shot
at winning 256 dollars
that's a [ __ ] stimulus check you
understand me
there's no better way to put your
college basketball knowledge
to the test than to put your money where
your mouth is with draftking sports book
college ball ain't for you okay we got
the nba
we got [ __ ] hockey we got [ __ ]
golf
we got a world-class casino blackjack
polka baccarat we got boost we got daily
boost
this is not gambling this is fun you
keep it under control
draftkings is safe secure reliable
you withdraw your money when you want
it's your [ __ ] money you [ __ ] momo
now i'm trying to make you some money
let's get on board
four dollars to win you 256 dollars
who's [ __ ] better than you nobody let
me ask you something
when you're sitting there smoking
[ __ ] reefer with some [ __ ]
third world nation chick licking your
nut sack and there you are with 200 and
well you're not gonna have 256 points at
that point you're gonna have like 195
left because you bought some wine and
some reefer and [ __ ] like that
are you gonna be [ __ ] smiling [ __ ]
yeah cause uncle joey
pointed you the draftking sportsbook app
download the top rated app today
and use promo code joey to turn four
[ __ ] dollars
into 256 dollars go bang your head
against the wall 15 times if you didn't
hear what i'm saying to you
and here's the part the lawyers make me
say you got to be 21 or older
new jersey indiana pa tennessee
[ __ ] colorado only new customers only
don't be pulling a [ __ ] quick louie
uncle joey's taking care of you here
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details if you got a
gaming problem
call 1-800 gambler or in indiana 1-809
with it we take that [ __ ] seriously
around here my mother was a degenerate
gambler
and i see where it ends but if you're
not don't have any problems
and you're [ __ ] tight and your [ __ ]
is [ __ ] straight
this is the way to do it four bucks to
win 256 dollars
on the biggest college tournament of the
year at sport at
draftkingsportsbookapp.com right now
download joey and get the [ __ ] making
some money
in a week you'll tweet me like all the
rest of these people and say joey
you're a [ __ ] animal thank you for
turning me on to draftkings
the joint is also brought to you by c
b d lion the [ __ ] bestie
what it was when here well joey i don't
know the guy
at the [ __ ] gas station told me that
listen he he works at a gas station for
a [ __ ] reason all right
he can't even change a flat i'm telling
you right now i just got [ __ ] clamps
moved out of my knees
and i'm telling you i've been with cbd
line before the surgery
and they were great after the surgery
that's when i really found out the power
of cbd line and what they have to offer
do me a favor
go to cbdlion.com right now read up on
cbd
cbn cby and all the [ __ ] great things
it does for you and could do for your
body
but it starts with you by going to
cbdline.com
take a look at what they got if it's the
cream you need
if it's the kinesiology tape if it's the
bath balls
if it's the capsules if it's the
chocolate
however way you want to ingest it they
have it let me tell you some of the
tincture is out of this [ __ ] world a
thousand milligram things
out of this world so start with
cbdlion.com right now
press and co joey and get 20 off your
first order delivered right to your
house do you understand me
church joey whatever [ __ ] you want
they're gonna give you 20
off that cbd line listen i want to thank
draftkings
i want to thank manscape and i want to
thank cbd lion
for being a part of this but most
importantly i want to thank you
[ __ ] for always being here and
having my back whether it's on here
twitter instagram or patreon i love you
[ __ ] have a great week
stay black and tell them uncle joey sent
you
they're not gonna do nothing here
anything i have to suck your dick so
gives a [ __ ]
stay black i love you
[Music]
so
you